Guys, in this training, I'm gonna be talking about something that you are not doing that
is costing you tens of thousands of dollars, and I say you're not doing, I'm not speaking
for 100% of people, but I'm speaking for 99% of people, okay?
And this is supposed to be live training, I tried to go live, I'm in London, hotel Wi-Fi
is crappy, so I'm just gonna record this, and then if you're watching this, it's because
it was posted.
I apologize, couldn't do it live.
That's how the cookie crumbles sometimes, guys.
So let me pull up my notes really quick, I want to make sure I'm not missing anything.
This is something, guys, what I'm gonna talk about today is something that I wish, I truly
wish that somebody would have told me and would have allowed me to do, would have encouraged
me to do, but that was not the case whatsoever, and I'll kind of get into what I mean by that
here in just a second, okay?
What I'm gonna talk about today is something that literally has made me, you know when
people say it's made me millions of dollars, and it just sounds cliche, this has actually
made me millions of dollars, I can definitively say it has made me not one, not two, multiple
millions of dollars, okay?
So let me start by saying this, guys, I grew up, let me get all this stuff out of my way
because I want to put my elbow here, because I grew up in a household and in a family and
in a community where I was taught that you should let your actions speak for themselves,
okay?
I was taught that you didn't need to talk about your success, you shouldn't talk about
your success, you should just do, okay?
Which I do respect, and I get, but that was how I grew up, okay?
And I'm guessing that a lot of you guys, because I know a lot of you guys and I've talked to
many of you, probably the majority of you I've had a conversation with, and I know you
guys grew up in similar kind of circumstances and similar kind of ways of growing up, okay?
And so I want to just talk about this for just a second, and for the record I just want
to mention that I do appreciate how I was brought up and I learned a lot from it and
in many, many ways I agree, okay?
However, I have to make a point, and we have to remember that the world is also different.
The world is very different than it was, you know, when I grew up in, let's say I was in
high school and I was 12, let's say 20 years ago, you know, the world 20 years ago compared
to today is not even, it doesn't even resemble, it's not even close, okay?
The world wasn't near as noisy, one, and attention wasn't near as valuable.
We live, and I know this kind of sounds like I'm stealing this from Gary V, because he
always says this, but we literally live in an attention economy, and the people that
make the money are the ones that know how to get attention and they convert it into
money, and that wasn't the case back then, okay?
So I don't fault my parents or anyone that grew up around me that was always encouraging
me not to talk, not to get attention, to lay low, to let my actions speak for themselves,
and that's just the advice that I was given, but I want you to keep in mind guys that as
of course our parents and the people that are around us were trying to do what's best
for us and what's right by us, but they, like, the world has changed, okay?
That's the point, okay?
And we are here to make money.
We are here talking about how do you make money, how do we get out of the rat race,
and so with that said guys, just know that the world has changed.
Alright, when I first started in 2016, this is nine years ago, I had the biggest scarcity
mindset in business, okay?
To the extent, guys, that I remember going through my Facebook friends and I thought,
you know what, anybody that's in my Facebook friends, that's in one of these rank and rent
and digital real estate or digital marketing groups, I'm deleting them as a friend, I don't
want to know you, I don't want to talk to you, I don't want you looking at my page and
seeing what pages I've liked, and then you can maybe find out my niche and you can see
that my clients are friends with me, and that's literally the way that I thought, and I remember
literally sitting there one day, and I went through, and anybody that was a friend that
had a mutual friend with a few different people that I knew were part of this other group,
I just deleted them, gone out of my life, don't care, don't want to talk to you, don't
want to, I wanted to be a fly on the wall, and I was that guy that would be in the group,
and I was consuming stuff, but I was very, there was no producing, there was no value
being added, it was just consume, go in, lurk, get out, okay?
I didn't interact, I didn't post, I didn't share, and I only came in the group to ask
questions when I absolutely had to, okay?
And that was how I was, that was 2017, 18-ish, okay?
Probably up until about 2019.
Somewhere along the line, this is where we're going to get into what I want to share with
you guys, somewhere along the line, I started noticing, you know, I heard people point this
out and they talked about this attention thing, but I started noticing people that were like
really taking off, and we're talking about the, you know, Grant Cardona, I don't know,
from like 2012 to 2020, he had this tremendous, still very relevant, but had this huge run,
and he was, you know, very captivating and polarizing, and I watched him, obviously Gary
Vee, and then I remember watching just somebody like Jake Paul, this is 2019, 2020, and just
people were like, that guy, he's kind of a clown, but that dude knows how to get attention,
he's a genius marketer, and I was like, yeah, they're actually right, this guy knows how
to get attention, and so as I saw this and I saw what he was doing, Jake Paul was taking
his attention, he was getting attention, he was turning it into, in the case now, since
2020, 2019, he was turning it into fights, where he'd go, you know, create these fights,
he'd get a bunch of people to view it, and he was making millions, and he still is making
millions and millions of dollars, and so that was when I realized like, there's something
here, and I'm missing something, and yeah, it's embarrassing, and yeah, I didn't grow
up like this, and yeah, you know, I'm not making that much money, but there is value
in building an audience, okay, and so here's what I did, and this is where I went right,
and I didn't, I had to do it very strategically because the groups that I were in, they did
not, they did not encourage this, in fact, they really hated this because they felt threatened
that somebody was gonna come in and take their business or have more influence, whatever,
and I have a complete opposite approach, but anyway, 2020, guys, as I started scaling
up, as I started going on my run, as I started, and my run being from eight to 10,000 bucks,
scaling up to that $100,000 per month mark, I just intuitively knew like, Nick, you need
to share your story, you need to start, you know, adding value, I didn't know at that
time what it was gonna be worth, I didn't know if people were gonna resonate with it,
but I just started sharing my journey, I started sharing the deals that I was closing, I shared
when we added $10,000 in one month in revenue, I shared when I figured out the lead value
calculator, I remember making the video talking about the lead value calculator in one of
my groups, I was in Virginia, and I sat in my hotel room, and I was like, this is like
the most genius way to come up with pricing, and it's working for me, let me go ahead and
make this video, and I shared it in the group, and people loved it, and I was just, I probably
made like, in 2020, I probably made like eight to 10 posts, it's nothing crazy, but it was
just the things I was learning, the wins, I didn't share, I didn't have a ton of losses,
to be honest, but I didn't share a lot of losses, which I wish I would have shared more
of, but I just started sharing stuff, man, I just started sharing my journey, and scary
at first, I remember, you know, pushing posts on some of these different posts, and just
wondering if anyone was gonna like it, or if it was gonna be that post that had one
like or no likes, and it was three days later, but people really, really liked it, and so
what happened, started happening, guys, is over time, throughout 20, I did this in 2020,
then I did it again in 2021, and over time, guys, I started building this little micro
following inside of some of these groups, just by sharing my story, and sometimes the
people would actually reach out to me and ask me questions, other times, and I didn't
even know this, people would just kind of keep an eye on me, maybe they wouldn't even
add me as a friend, I only found this out like three, four years later, when people,
let's say, some of you guys, some of you are those people, had joined this group or
got on a call with me and said, hey, I remember you in such and such group, the posts that
you're making, and I saw one of them, and I remember thinking like, I gotta watch out
for this guy, right? Guys, doing this, I did this for two years, all of 2020, all of 2021,
it did not make me any money, like it didn't make me $0, so imagine every time I wrote
a post, let's say it took me 30 minutes to write a thought provoking, not a thought provoking,
an experience that also was thought provoking post, I wasn't seeing money from that 30 minutes,
right? But I guess just deep down, I knew that it was gonna be worth it, so I kept doing it,
kept doing it, kept doing it, again, 2020, 2021, and guys, by the end of 2021,
that all changed, because I was getting so many messages from people,
not even just following me, but people were literally sending me messages, hey, how you
doing this, how you coming up with the price, how you getting the flat fee deal, how'd you do the
pre-sale, how'd you do 10,000 a month, how did you do this, and I was answering all the questions
that I could, but I knew that I was just drowning, because there's no way I could keep up with all
of it, so that's when I started putting everybody in a free Facebook group, and just sharing what
was working once, and letting everybody consume it, okay? And so, what ended up happening from
that, and this is where I made my money, and I'm not saying that your journey's gonna be the exact
same, but you guys are gonna be surprised at the different opportunities that are gonna be there,
if you guys will build a following, if you will create influence, if you will
make yourself an authority in this space, and in this group, and I'm literally giving you the
platform, I'm asking you to do it, I'm allowing you to do it, and it sounds like funny, but
I was never part of groups where they let you do that. Every time I would make a post,
it's like, what are you trying to do, what are you trying to sell, I'm like, I'm not trying to sell
anything, I'm just trying to let people know what I'm up to, and trust that I know what I'm talking
about, because if I end up doing something, I wanna have people that have seen me, that know me,
that trust me, okay? So guys, I put all these people in a Facebook group, I've been doing this
for two years, making these posts, people have been following me, and I realized based on the
feedback, and the questions, and the DMs, I was like, people need what I have, people wanna know
how to sell, people, you know, yeah, there's a million courses out there that teach you how
to rank a website, there's a million courses that teach you how to get leads, and a lot of them are
good, but most of these people do not know how to sell, they do not know who to call, how to call,
what to say, how to overcome objections, how to send a screencast that's gonna eliminate the
objections, how to close, what happens if, they don't know any of this stuff, and this is the
stuff that I'm good at, this is stuff that I've been perfecting, guys, for, you know, for two years,
I mean, more like six, but two years just grinding it out, and so what I ended up doing is I ended
up saying, you know what, I'm gonna start a program, this ended up being Digital Landlords,
I'm gonna start a program, and I'm going to start with a beta group, and I'm gonna take a certain
amount of students, and I'm gonna take them, I'm gonna train them, I'm gonna do everything that
can give them the best service I can possibly give them, at a discount, because they're taking
a risk with me, because I have no credentials, I have no, you know, case studies, whatever,
and I'm gonna go help them have tremendous success, and from that, then I'm gonna like
really launch my program, and see where I can take this thing, and so guys, what I ended up doing is
I went into my Facebook group, I went live the day before Thanksgiving, I jumped on, I said, look,
here's the deal, I wanna start a program, I'm gonna teach everything that I know about selling,
about scaling, about doing this business the way that I've done it, that allowed me to get to
$100,000 per month, if you wanna check out the offering, get on a webinar on Monday, that's it,
fill out an application that says you wanna apply to the actual call, I'm gonna be pitching you guys
on what the offer is, but if you want, it's gonna be discounted, because guess what, there is no
program, I'm gonna teach it to you live, there is no Facebook group, I'm gonna create it as soon as
we do this webinar, I have nothing to show, so you have to just have faith in me and what I'm doing,
and so I did this webinar the next Monday, and I had, I think it was 32 or 33 people show up,
and there was only one person that did not buy, now they all didn't buy right on the spot, but
within a few days, the few people that didn't buy, we ended up working out some kind of a resolution,
and there was only one person that, by the way, that same person, I see them all the time kicking
around the free groups, kicking around the free resources, it's been three years now, and they're
still stumbling around trying to avoid paying the piper, it's hilarious, and I always see them,
and I'm like, that's funny, that's the one person that didn't buy. Guys, that first day,
I made almost 100,000 bucks, I was like 97,000, literally, I don't know, I almost made 100,000
bucks in that very first day. Now, why do I tell you that? Because that all came and that was all
possible because I built influence, because I built a micro following, I didn't know what it
was gonna look like, I didn't know if I was gonna do a program, I didn't know if I was gonna do
consulting, I didn't know if I was gonna do anything, but I spent the time, I made about
10 posts in 2020, I probably made the same in 2021, I answered people's questions, I was active
in the group, I spent time in the DMs, not a lot of time, but I spent time, and I just started
building my brand as Nick Wood, as somebody who owns this agency called Evergreen, and I started
building this little micro following inside of this really unknown niche called Rankin Rent,
inside of a few Facebook groups, just by sharing my story, just by sharing my wins,
sharing a few losses, commenting, giving my input, sharing a tip here, sharing a strategy,
that's all that I did, guys, and literally made on my very first day when I decided to monetize
this, I made 100,000 bucks, give or take, let's call it 95,000, and literally some of these people
had just seen a post, and that's it, that's it. So what I'm telling you guys to do, guys,
and I'm encouraging you to do, and what I'm suggesting you do, and by the way, I apologize,
I'm kind of trying to talk a little bit quiet, I can hear somebody's outside cleaning,
I got people next door, I'm trying to be a little bit quiet and respectful here,
as I'm in the hotel room, and it's the afternoon, but guys, I'm asking you to do the same thing,
okay, and I'm gonna tell you why I'm suggesting it, what's in it for me, because there is a benefit
for me, and I'm gonna tell you why here in just a second, but I'm not only allowing you to do it,
I'm asking you to do it, I'm suggesting you do it, and it is going to be worth your time,
and I'm not saying that you're gonna start a program, I'm not saying you're gonna do anything
with it immediately, but heaven forbid you build a following, you're already in the group, you're
already asking questions, already finding out answers, if you find out a new answer, you find
out some little thing, it takes you five minutes to go and post about it, right, it's not much,
but heaven forbid you get down the road and you end up meeting somebody who has something
that's really valuable, maybe it's some AI tool that's really valuable for flipping websites,
you know, spinning up websites, whatever, quickly, and you now have, oh, you have an audience, you
have a following, you have a built-in customer base, and those posts that you made when you
had nothing to offer are going to be worth thousands of dollars. Now, the hard part about
this, guys, is that you're not gonna see the money immediately, you don't even know how it's gonna
work, you don't know how you're gonna monetize it, you don't know if you're ever gonna monetize it,
but I will tell you guys that it will be worth your time, even if you don't end up monetizing it,
because I think eventually you will, but even if you never do, it's still gonna be worth your time,
so here's, and my goal was initially, because I was gonna have Porter on this call, I was gonna
have him share his thoughts, because I had this conversation with Porter when he first started,
he was really being quiet, he wasn't sharing a lot, he grew up in the same household as me,
don't talk, don't, whatever, whatever, whatever, and he's even more conservative and, what's the
word, not the same, like he's even more reserved, I guess, than I am, I wanted to have him share
his experience, and I was like, dude, you gotta share, you gotta share your posts, you gotta share
your wins, and you guys don't have to do it in a braggadocious way, you don't have to do it in a
loud manner, like I sometimes come across, I know, I know, it's annoying, but here's what I'm asking
you guys to do, okay, asking you, number one, first of all, you gotta fix your head, you gotta
create an abundance mindset that you know that sharing is not only not gonna hurt you, but it's
the single best thing you can do for yourself, you're building authority, you're building a
micro audience inside of your community, or inside of here, inside of the free Facebook group,
inside of the school community, but you have to have an abundance mindset, you have to realize
that sharing is not gonna hurt you, okay, it's not gonna hurt you, in fact, it's going to help you,
period, okay, again, I'm not only letting you do it, but I'm asking you to do it, okay, so here's
what I'm suggesting that you do, is what I would suggest doing is commit to spending the time
to being vulnerable about your journey, and you're all gonna have different journeys, some of you
guys are gonna get a deal right out the gate, and you're gonna just go, some of you guys are gonna
get a deal out the gate, then you're gonna stumble, and you're gonna get distracted, and you're gonna
leave for six months, and come back, some of you guys are not gonna get a deal for six months, and
then you're gonna get a deal, and then you're gonna crush it, everybody's got a different story,
but I just am imploring you to just share your story, the things you're learning, the things that
the mistakes you've made, the losses, the wins, everything, okay, all I'm asking to do in terms
of like actual actions, is commit to doing two posts a week, okay, that's it, pick two days,
pick two days, Monday, Thursday, Tuesday, Friday, Tuesday, Wednesday, and share a simple win or loss
or lesson learned, and that's it, okay, if you were actually, if you planned out your month,
and you said, hey, I'm gonna do it on these days, there's eight different posts I'm gonna make,
on Sunday, I'm gonna think, what did I learn last week, I'm gonna come up with five ideas,
I'm gonna choose two of them, and I'm gonna share them on those two days, I'm gonna put a picture,
so it makes a little bit more interesting, I'm gonna just think of something interesting to say
in the first line, so people actually know this is a valuable post, and you spent, I bet you that
would take you 30 minutes a week, with the ideas, with the posting, with the whole deal, okay,
two posts, two days, sharing a win or a loss, lesson learned, that's what I'm asking you to do,
do it every single week, and keep doing it, and do it forever, just get used to it, just make it
a habit, just the same way that you freaking drink water, because we're never gonna stop drinking
water, we're never gonna stop eating, we're never gonna stop sleeping, it's just part of what you do,
is you put out content, and you look at it as, hey, I'm producing, I'm doing something that's
adding value, and just becomes part of who you are, and some of you guys that are having a hard
time following what I'm saying, do it because you're helping people, what you guys don't
understand is that a lot of people are watching you, a lot of people are watching you specifically,
you that's listening, they relate to you, not me, not to Kyle, not to Francesco, not to Porter,
but you, for whatever reason, because maybe you're a cop, or maybe you're a school teacher,
or maybe you're a single mom, but it's you that they noticed, and they're waiting for you to fail
or to succeed, and you have no idea how much that does for people, okay, now, let me tell you the
benefits of this, okay, number one, as I said, which is obvious, is you're gonna be building an
audience, you're gonna be building authority, and I assure you that at some future period,
it will be worth your time, and you will be able to cash out later on, I promise you, you will be
able to cash out, okay, you might not choose to, but you will have the option, you will have,
you're building, you're literally putting money, it's kind of like you have a future credit to
cash out, okay, number two, this is another benefit you're gonna have, forget about building an
audience, forget about, you know, a following, but you are doing this, guys, you hold yourself
accountable, when you do this, when you tell people what you're up to, you know, what your goals are,
hey, I'm gonna do this much money, you know, Porter's announced that many times, he's gonna
do $25,000 by the end of the year, he is holding himself accountable, doing this will make you more
money, because you're gonna be talking about your goals, you're gonna be talking about your dreams,
you're gonna be talking about the things that you're planning on doing, you're committing to
doing, it is going to make you more money, okay, and guys, part of that is that when you start
talking about it, in some of these other groups, like the school community inside of the free
Facebook group, I actually, if you send anyone to us, I actually pay you guys a really good
affiliates, there's somebody in this group, I'm not gonna mention their name, but they've made
over 6,000 bucks, just sharing a few wins, and me paying them, because they've sent, I create a
custom application, you get it, they send it, all you have to do is send it to them, they fill it
out, and we close them, you get paid, and it's great money, okay, that's just a side benefit,
but guys, it will make you more money, because it's gonna hold you accountable, okay,
the next thing it's gonna do, guys, it's gonna give you clarity and more understanding about
the things that you're learning, when you teach somebody else something that you learned,
it makes it that much more clear in your mind, when you teach somebody something that you've
learned, and you try to articulate it on paper, or on a post, you learn it better, because you're
now explaining, now you're the teacher, and it makes it, it becomes more clear by you doing that,
okay, so it's very, like that to me is huge, whenever I learn something, and then I post it,
I really sit down, I articulate it correctly, and it forces me to explain it in a way that
people understand it, and it makes me learn it better, okay, and the last benefit, guys,
is you are going to inspire and help people way more than you have, you have no idea how much
people are watching, I remember looking at posts that would inspire me, that got me excited, I
remember being on a cruise back in 2019, when I was determining, should I stay, should I go,
and I was just binge watching, I was binge watching the specific person's videos,
and it did everything to me, I was on at the gym, I would listen to their videos,
and I don't know, man, for some reason, I just related to this specific individual,
and it got me excited, it gave me that fire, that juice, that drive again,
and that was one of the reasons why I stayed, one of the reasons why I kept doing this,
and I was eight, nine months at that point, this is early December 2019, from being at
a hundred thousand bucks per month, okay, so guys, why would I want you to do this, well, because
what it does is actually, it helps both of us, okay, number one, it allows you to grow your
audience for free, you get to build a community within the community, and for me, it serves a
social proof, right, it serves as social proof for people that are in here that are struggling,
that are like, hey, Porter's getting a deal, he's doing the same thing as I'm doing, well,
clearly, it works, right, inside of here, and also, guys, when you share this inside of school,
when you share this inside of the free Facebook group, you have no idea how much that helps me
for social proof, and people, I could say stuff, I could show people how much money I've made,
I could show you my tax returns, I could show you my Stripe accounts, you could talk to my clients,
but for some reason, it just comes out different, and it comes out better when it comes from
somebody else, okay, so for me, it'd be a huge help, and that's the benefit for me, it's going
to give me that social proof, okay, the other thing that it's going to do for me, and for you,
is it's going to bring excitement, it's going to bring energy, it's going to bring that freaking
zeal to this group of, hey, we're closing freaking deals, John Jarwood, he just got a deal,
Irwin just got a deal, Porter just got another deal, Francesca just slammed the deal, what the
heck am I doing, right, it brings the energy, it brings the excitement, and it's intoxicating,
it's amazing, okay, and guys, I will tell you, I pay attention, I know who's active,
I see who posts, I see who comments, I see who is actually doing production, and is giving value,
and who's just a leak, just so you guys know, okay, and I appreciate it, and I will always take care
of you guys, so my challenge to you guys is that you fix your head, you create an abundance
mindset, say, hey, look, you know, and I'm not telling you, you need to go and share exact cities
and exact niches of what you're in, no, I'm not saying that, but if you learn something, if you
go through the trouble of finding something out, go share it, I promise you, I know it sounds like
it's going to be a bad decision, and you're going to create your own competition, guys, I've been
sharing everything I know for years, and it's not ever hurt me, okay, it has never hurt me, you just
got to have an abundance mindset, and you have to know that, hey, I'm somebody that's always in the
game, I'm somebody that's going to be learning the next thing, the next tip, the next trick,
so no matter what I share today, I'm going to have something new tomorrow, and I'm going to help a
bunch of people, and by doing that, they're going to trust me, they're going to follow me, and you
know what, down the road, I might cash in on that thing, I might, okay, so get the abundance mindset,
and all I ask you to do is commit to doing two posts a week, okay, pick two days, share a lesson
learned, a loss, a win, a lesson learned, share it, it doesn't have to be long, it could be a freaking
one line, it could be two lines, it could be a paragraph, it could be a couple paragraphs,
it could be a novel, I don't care, you could have a photo, you don't have to have a photo,
you could do a video, you could do a picture, you could do, I do not care, share two posts a week,
and then when people comment, interact with them, hey, yeah, clarify this, that, and the rest,
guys, this will change everything for you, when you start doing this, it's going to bring you
more clarity, it's going to hold you accountable, it's going to make you more money, and of course,
it's going to help me at the same time. If I had known this, guys, and I had started doing this back
in 2016, and I had shared my journey of, hey, here's where I'm at, and I just got this towing
deal, and then I got this crawl space deal, and oh, I got distracted, and now I'm over here,
those would be the most valuable posts ever, and I'd probably have 10 times more people following
me, and I probably, instead of making $100,000 my very first day, I probably would have made $250,000,
but I didn't know this, and nobody ever told me to do this, and nobody encouraged me to do this,
and nobody allowed me to do it, here I am, I have a community, I've built of 800 people inside this
group, 6,000 people inside of digital, art of digital real estate, and 250 plus, some of the,
you know, there's some overlap from these groups, inside of the school community, the art, sorry,
the rank and rent academy, and I'm letting you guys go and frickin' build your own network,
your own following within my groups that I've built with my money, with my attention, with the
people, with the videos that I've put up, and the production team that I have paid to put them on
YouTube, and to monitor the comments and everything else, I'm letting you tap into that 100% free,
why? Because I want social proof, I want to grow, I want you to grow, that's what this is about,
so guys, you don't have to do this, you can be like I was for the first little bit,
and I was Mr. hey, I'm not even gonna have a website, I'm gonna go get to a million
bucks a year, no website, no brand, I'm proud about it, screw you guys, you don't need it,
whatever, and I did that, okay, but all I can think about now, now that I've made millions of
dollars from doing this, literally millions of dollars from just sharing my journey,
I can't imagine how much money I left on the table, if I would have shared, yeah, I did it
without, I got $100,000 per month without a website, without a brand, nothing, great, good
job, Nick, pat on the back, how much money did you lose out on? I ask myself that all the time,
and I know it's a lot of freaking money, okay, so guys, this is something that if you are not
doing currently, I strongly encourage you, you are missing out on thousands of dollars,
thousands and hundreds of thousands of, possibly millions of future dollars,
it takes a couple minutes a week, just like the slide edge we've been talking about, guys,
you just put this in your calendar, you do it twice a week, it takes you less than 30 minutes,
complete, total 30 minutes, and you start building an audience, and I'm telling you guys in three,
four, one, two years, this is gonna pay off, so guys, I appreciate you watching this video,
I would love, I pay attention, I'd love for you guys to start doing this, it will help me,
it will help you, it will hold you accountable, guys, let's go get it, I've been there, I've done
it, you don't have to listen to what I'm saying, but I do know a thing or two, and I wish I would
have done this earlier, so guys, thanks for watching this video, thanks for watching this
training, I'll see you guys next Tuesday.